We've already touched on ethers
in several videos.
They've been our useful aprotic
solvent in several of
our reactions.
But I thought it was about time
that we actually devoted
a video or two to ethers.
And like all things that we've
done in organic chemistry, a
good way to familiarize
ourselves with the molecules
and how they look, is to
actually name them.
So let's do a couple.
And the first few you've
seen already.
So let's say we have this
molecule right here.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to teach you two
ways to name it.
The common name, and that's
probably the more important
one, especially with ethers.
Because, as you could imagine,
that is the more common name.
That is what people say.
And then I'll also show
you how to name it
using the IUPAC name.
So let me write this down.
IUPAC name, which is the
International Union of Pure
and Applied Chemistry.
And they've come up with kind
of the official naming
protocols for all of these
organic molecules.
This is actually the convention
that we used
earlier when we did the alkanes
and the alkenes.
But in the case of ethers, the
common name is more common.
So the common name for this
molecule right here.
You look at the two carbon
groups here.
So let's see.
You have this one right here.
That is an ethyl group.
That's an ethyl group
right there.
You have one, two carbons.
And then you look at the other
carbon group right over there.
That's also an ethyl group.
You have one, two carbons.
So you call this-- let me just
write this down-- that is also
an ethyl group.
So the common name for this
is just diethyl ether.
And the ether tells you, this
part tells you, that you have
an oxygen in between your
two ethyl groups.
This is the common name.
Now the International Union of
Pure and Applied Chemistry
official name for it.
You kind of do something similar
to how we named other
things before.
You look for the
longest chain.
Let me redraw it.
So maybe on the left hand side
I'll do the common names.
On the right hand side I'll
do the IUPAC names.
So let me redraw what
the common name
of the diethyl ether.
You look for the
longest chain.
In this case, there's
two longest chains.
There's this one that has
one, two carbons.
And then you have this one,
that has one, two carbons.
So you can pick either one.
I'll just pick this one as the
main chain right over there.
It has two carbons,
no double bonds.
It is an ethane.
And then you say, OK, I have
this alkoxy group.
We put the oxy at the end of it
because it has this oxygen
right here.
But it's the alk part of it
has two carbons, one, two.
So we call this right here,
we call this ethoxy.
So one other way to name this,
we have this ethoxy group
attached to the one carbon.
We're just going to start
numbering on this side of the
ethane, just because that's
where the group is, attached
to the one carbon.
So we call this 1-ethoxyethane.
You'll almost never see it
actually named this way, even
though this is the
official name.
You're much more likely to see
this as diethyl ether.
And at least in my brain, this
resonates a lot more.
You just say what are
the two groups.
And you throw the
ether at end.
You know that there's an
oxygen in between.
Let's do a couple
more of these.
So let's say I have this
molecule right here.
I have this molecule
right over here.
The common way is you look at
the two groups on either side
of the oxygen.
So this right here-- let me do
this in a different color--
this group on the left
right here, we have
one, two, three carbons.
It's a propyl group,
but we're attached
to that middle carbon.
So this is an isopropyl group.
And on the right hand
side right here, we
just have one carbon.
So this is right here-- I keep
using that blue-- this right
here, this is a methyl group.
So the common way of naming
it, you just list both of
these groups and then
you write ether.
And you list them in
alphabetical order.
I comes before m.
So this is, the common name
is isopropyl methyl ether.
Now if we were to do the IUPAC
naming, we look for the
longest carbon chain.
Let me redraw the
molecule itself.
So let me redraw the same
thing right there.
So what's the longest
carbon chain here?
Well we have one, two, three
carbons right there.
We only have one carbon
right there.
So this thing right here is
our longest carbon chain.
It has three carbons on it, and
it had no double bonds.
So eth, meth, prop, propyl,
or it's actually propane.
So this is our longest. So we
write propane right there,
because we're using the IUPAC
naming mechanism.
And then we look at this methoxy
group right here.
And I call this a methoxy group,
because I have the o.
That gives us the oxy.
And I just have a methyl
group right here.
So this is methoxy.
You remember that meth is the
prefix for just having only
one carbon.
We add the oxy because
that oxygen is there.
And it's attached to the two
carbons on the propane chain,
no matter what direction you
start naming from, or
numbering from.
One, two, three.
So this is 2-methoxypropane.
Let's do another one.
Let's do one more.
And I think you'll get the
gist of at least the
reasonably simple
ethers to name.
So let's put a ring
over there.
And then that's attached
to an oxygen.
And then we have another carbon
chain right here.
chain right there.
Let me just copy and paste
that so that I don't
have to redraw it.
So let me copy and paste.
All right.
So let's do the common name
first. That always tends to be
a little bit more fun.
So on this side, we have one,
two, three, four, five, six
carbons in a cycle.
This right here on the
left hand side is
a cyclohexyl group.
This on the right hand side,
we have one, two, three.
This is just a straight-up
propyl group.
And so when you name the ether,
you just put these two
groups in alphabetical
order, and you add an
ether at the end.
So it's cyclohexyl.
C comes before p.
So it's cyclohexyl propyl.
Let me get that shade
of yellow right.
Cyclohexyl propyl ether.
Now let's do the IUPAC
way to name it.
So you look for the longest
carbon chain here.
In this case, it's going to be
the cyclohexane right here.
We have one, two, three, four,
five, six carbons there.
We only have one, two,
three there.
So this is kind of
our backbone.
So we write down cyclohexane.
No double bonds, so
it's a hexane.
So that's the cyclohexane
right there.
If you just had these three
carbons, it would be a propyl.
But this is not just
three carbons.
It's three carbons and
then an oxygen.
So we would call it a propoxy.
So this is propoxy group.
And you don't have to number
it because it can just be
attached to any of
these carbons.
It would essentially be
the same molecule.
So you can just call this
propoxy cyclohexane.
Let me make it a little bit
closer to the cyclohexane.
Propoxy cyclohexane.
But once again the common
name is what you're
more likely to see.
Now that we've named a few of
them, let's think a little bit
about their properties.
What we've seen already is
that-- and we've used it
several times, especially in our
Sn2 reactions and things
like that-- places where
we didn't want
protons floating around.
We used actually
diethyl ether.
And in general ethers do
make for good solvents.
They tend to be fairly
unreactive.
So good solvents.
Especially when you're looking
for an aprotic solvent.
Remember, aprotic means you
don't have hydrogens that can
kind of lose their electron to
maybe an electronegative atom
like an oxygen.
And then the proton just floats
around, and then can go
and react with other things.
This does not have any hydrogens
directly bonded to
an oxygen in any
of these cases.
So it is an aprotic solvent.
And because it doesn't have any
hydrogens bonded to the
oxygen, you also have
no hydrogen bonding.
And just as a bit of a review,
you know that in water you
have the situation-- let me draw
some water molecules-- in
water you have the situation
where the
oxygen hogs the electrons.
So it has a partial
negative charge.
Hydrogen gets its electrons
hogged or taken away, or it
spends less time with them.
So it has a partial
positive charge.
So this oxygen will have a
partial negative charge.
And so the hydrogens with the
partial positive charge are
attracted to the oxygens with
the partial negative charge.
And you have this hydrogen
bonding.
And this hydrogen bonding
makes water.
It pulls the molecules
together.
So you need to put more energy
into it for it to either melt,
or for it to actually boil.
And for the molecules to
kind of get ripped
away from each other.
And that's also true
with alcohols.
Alcohols only have one hydrogen
to each oxygen, but
they still have the hydrogen
bonding going on.
In the case of ethers, there
is no hydrogen bonding.
I'll represent each of
the carbon chains
with an R and an R.
I'll write R prime right here
to show that it could be a
different carbon chain
than this right here.
And the R stands for radical.
Not to be confused with
free radical.
Completely different things.
This R just means really
a carbon chain
attached to this oxygen.
But here there's no hydrogen
getting its electrons hogged
by oxygens with partial
positive and
partial negative charges.
So you're not going to have that
type of hydrogen bonding.
And because of that, ethers have
much lower melting and
boiling points.
It's much easier.
You have to put less heat into
the system for these molecules
to break away from each other,
because they aren't attracted
to each other as much.